hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast education training CPD from
the Chinese perspective by Dr William
Pang I'm Christina juwel of labits and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational seminar is presented
by labro the leading scientific social
network working website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this website is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or you may submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker Dr
William Pang Dr Pang joined Sofi in
January 2011 as a director providing
expertise to the asia-pacific region for
animal research and Welfare related
Affairs Dr Pang received his bachelor
degree in veterinary medicine and an MS
in Veterinary pathology from the College
of veterinary medicine at China
agricultural University Beijing China Dr
Pang received his PhD in veterinary
medicine from University College Dublin
Ireland he did a postdoc training in lab
animal medicine at University of
Copenhagen
Denmark Dr Pang has over 30 Publications
six book chapters and is invited to many
seminars before his copi tenure he
worked with two US headquartered cros in
China as attending vet and director of
Veterinary Services where he led the
animal care and use programs to aaaac
full accreditation he also served as
study director for pre-clinical
development in multispecies acute and
general toxicology programs Dr Pang is
acam board certified and currently
serves as a council member for aaaac
international for Dr Ping's complete bio
please visit labs.com I will now turn it
over to Dr William Pang for his
presentation
Dr
Pang uh hello everyone thanks very much
for the invite from Lab roads and thanks
very much for intruction given by
Christina so today I'm speaking to you
uh from Beijing China about a topic
which is entitled education training CPD
in left animal sciences and medicine
from the Chinese
perspective
uh so today I'm going to uh cover such
topics as listed uh here so I'm going to
give you guys a very brief introduction
about the
regulations of uh lap animals in China
and then talk about the topics about the
education training CPD in Leb science
and
medicine so the leban regulations in
China are very different from the
Western countries so basically I listed
the different types of regulations and
their respective titles and the uh
Authority uh with regard to the
regulation or implementing those
regulations so the most important one is
the very first one is a administrative
regulation named as regulations for the
administration of Affairs concerning
experimental animals issued by the
ministry of Science and Technology it
can be abbreviated or shortened as most
m o which is the government body
regulating leer animals in China and
then within different departments within
different uh uh provinces we have
different uh departmental bylaws and
local laws and the standards so those
are very important regulations I gu
guidelines you have to know if you are
working in China or you are planning to
work in China in the lab animal science
field so this regulation issued by most
is actually was uh in 1988 it's bit old
so the Chinese government and the lab
animal science Community are revising it
updating yet in the the the procession
has been ongoing for the past 10 years
or so so hopefully we will get this
updated version of the regulation within
a couple of years so basically this
regulation covers everything about
animals which are purpose bread for use
in scientific research testing and
teaching so as related to the topic
today so the most important thing is the
third one which is regarding ing the
employment of qualified staff so we are
going to talk about the qualifications
educations trainings needed for those
people to be involved with laboratory
animals so they can be on board and work
efficiently so in this uh picture you
can see that the lab animal
Administration system in China so most
importantly the thing is on the uh left
hand uh top corner of this slide which
is the department in charge which is uh
most Ministry of Science and Technology
they provide oversight to all the
animals uh used Brad in China so at
different Province level such as in
Beijing Shanghai uh and other provinces
we have a bureau of science and
technology or some parts of the ch of
the country may call this organization
as Department of uh science and
technology so it could be post or uh do
do so these provincial level offices
actually
administer uh the review and approval
and also authorization of the lab animal
license approvable so the labory animal
license in China will have two types of
licenses one is for the facility or you
can call it establishments so for the
Animal Facility you have to have a
license before you can run your business
and for the individuals we have
individual
license and the other departments like
the Ministry of Education Ministry of
Health Ministry of Agriculture China
Food and Drug Administration China FDA
and the Bureau of Forestry when the W
animals like n primates are involved
they are getting involved and regarding
the uh lab animal importing and
exporting so the China inspection and
quarantine Bureau will be
involved and in addition to the
regulations from the uh central
government level and also from the local
government level there are many many
China national standards for L animals
so we started this national standards
system back in
1994 so the uh Chinese pronunciation for
national standards are GB so we also
call it in China as GB so we have about
of little bit over 100 laary animal
related standards or GB in total plus
some 20 local standards covering a lot
of uh non
routine uh lepo animal species such as
TRS zebra fishes in addition to lab
rodents rabbits non pids so also uh get
some kind of interaction I mean the uh
cross administrational regulations like
GP like GMP like lab Animal Facility
construction standards
so in total about 100 so in order to
work in China you need to be uh pretty
familiar with those kind of um uh
national standards or GBS because when
you are applying for the establishment
license or facility license or
individual license you need to be uh
studying those kind of naal Standards
because they are in the
exams so another uh picture uh much
clear so in the uh Ministry of Science
and Technology we have an expert
committee it's kind of Advisory Board
which was established back in November
2010 so they are providing advices and
providing strategic thinking advices to
these uh Ministry and then at Province
level they also have that but usually
and the bureau or Committee of Science
and Technology at different cities or
different provinces they will have an
Administration office for labor animals
such as in Beijing it's called Beijing
admin Administration office for labor
animals we call it Bola b a
o l a so uh so they also have an expert
panel to assist in the
administrations and uh it used to be uh
regulated by this office to do the kind
of review and approval for licensing on
certifying lab facilities and also for
the individual training and
qualification and certifications but now
probably about five or six years ago so
the administration office which is a
government body they transferred these
kind of UH
responsibilities to a kind of uh uh
Community or Association type of
organizations in Beijing is called
Beijing Association on lab animal care
so they are arranging different training
workshops and uh um administ
administrate the examinations for those
individuals but as I said uh previously
that the licensing and certifying laor
animal facilities is still the
responsibility of the administration
office for La
animals so uh so the administration for
the Lal system in China the uh legal
basis for that is actually coming from
the
2001 uh regulations which is called
animal license management regulations so
it says that all Chinese institutions or
and other uh foreign institutions like
some of the farmer company uh contract
research organizations they have
presence they have facilities in China
so they operate in China so as they are
related to uh that breeding using
selling and transporting animals have to
apply a license before they can start to
run their businesses and in the licensed
facilities the personnel related to care
or use of leory animals are trained and
passed the examinations that is they are
qualified so the facilities are also
tested and achieved the national
standards so rather uh we are using kind
of engineering standard versus
performance standards performance
standard so again I need to emphasize
that in China Ministry of science and
technology is the government body
responsible for administration of labory
animal related Affairs so the province
is government for local labory animal
Affairs under the
instructions
of most or oversight of
most so the you know we need to know
that what kind of knowledge what kind of
training we will be needed in order to
be qualified to practice uh kind of of
Laban medicine and all Laban science
like you know man manipulating lab
animals do procedures whatever in China
so we need to know we have a you know we
need to have we must have the basic
knowledge of management of La animals
and rela laws and regulations it is
similar as in the US the laws are
published by the uh the the Congress in
China we called people's Congress and
also the regulations Reg ations are
usually issued by the government bodies
not by the Congress so the and also we
need to know a little bit about the
selection a proper selection and use of
Le animals to meet your scientific goals
and also we have to know about the
quality control of Le animals uh from
the uh microbiology uh genetics and also
from the welfare
standpoints and uh we need to know the
commonly used laor animals and their
management mainly husbandry
and care and use and factors affecting
La animals and animal experiments and
basic knowledge and skills of animal
experimentation development and
application of anim models nowadays we
focus more on the uh transgenic animals
including transgenic mice rats and zebra
fish and we also need to know about how
to care those animals uh doing good care
uh providing a good
care for those animals especially
nowadays the humanized anim models
mainly mice so managemental facilities
for animal housing and breeding and we
have to have a sound understanding of
the professional eth ethics of the
Personnel engaged in the management of
lap animals we have a kind of eth
committee also called I in China and the
uh class hour uh of the training course
uh should not be less than 25
hours and this license individual
license are renewed uh every five years
you need to know those updates in
regulations and the updates of those
best practices and you need to sit in
exam and pass that in order to be
recertified and uh as for the license in
certifying LA to facilities uh such as
uh in Beijing I use Beijing as an
example you need to first uh you need to
download the application form and you f
out this form and submit this to the uh
Administration office for lab anos
inion and then they will do a kind of
preliminary check so uh to find out
whether this package is complete if
there are any deficiencies in there and
if it's an deficiency un notified uh or
found uh you the form will return back
to you uh for further information and if
the application uh package looks okay
then they will be submitted and then a
set visit team assigned by the
administration office beijun will be
formed with appropriate experts present
in the set Vis team so this panel will
do
a uh kind of uh side uh visit uh to a
facility uh to um mainly based on the
regulation and also the Lal standards to
evaluate whether your facility and the
program are meeting the minimum
standards or requirements of the
regulation and guidelines and uh
actually before or shortly after the
onsight visit you need to uh do certain
um testings in the facility like the
environmental control or monitoring uh
data uh have to be submitted to the
administration office for review and if
the uh set visit was successful and then
the expert uh committee or panel will
propose to the Beijing Administration
office for approval that is a
certificate will be granted to the
applicant so usually in the certificate
uh it will be indicated which type of
animals uh usually based on the
microbiological status like SPF gen 3 uh
conventional animals whatever will be
mentioned and then the uh animal species
like um La RS mice guinea pigs
hamsters um pigs uh dogs whatever will
be clearly uh noted on the certificate
so you can can only house and use of
those animals listed on your
certificate otherwise there will be a
kind of deviation from the uh
certificate regulation if the C visit uh
was not successful and then a
notification will be sent to the
applicant and then you can uh make some
kind of corrective actions or provide
certain supplemental information until
you can be
uh uh reassessed and
approved and this license or certificate
is valid for 5 Years also and you need
to uh go through the renew process and
uh this just give you a brief idea about
uh what kind of contents or documents
are needed in the application package
for the certificate for La animal use I
mean from the for the establishment or
the fa for the facility so we need to
have the form we have three copies we
have to have a ethic committee or I cook
or chat we have to have a lot of uh
different Sops to cover laborary Animal
Care and use and facility operations and
we need to do uh and have the lab animal
environment testing reports uh
submitted uh to the government body
which is the Beijing Administration
office or in different
provinces and these tests uh have to be
performed by a government certified
third party elory that is you cannot do
it by
yourself and you have to provide at
least of certifi lab to animal personnel
and their certificate numbers and you
have to have a flow plan submitted and
you have to have a annual health check
certificate uh for the lab annual
personnel and also the annual
professional training schedule which are
also very important and you need to have
a in addition to the O chart of the
ethic committee review uh body you need
to also have policies on Animal Welfare
Val safety and ethic review
processes and the St Vis by exp so as I
mentioned though uh they do use a
checklist or score sheet uh including in
certain uh vetal items such as if you
don't have a uh ethic committee review
body which is a v item you are not going
to get the certificate if you don't have
a v there's no no to the certificate
you're not going to get it and the main
references are the national standards or
GBS so the some of the uh examples so if
you don't have certificate for the lab
personel you're not to get the
certificate uh you need to have a lab
animal quality manager you have to have
a facility manager you have certain
requirements for that for example at
least above associate bachelor degree uh
in lab animal science or
related field and also you have to have
a vet which is have
a social bachor degree in vet medicine
Plus at least three years of relevant
working experiences
and you have different Personnel
carrying for different categories of
animals and we do have a guidelines on
human treatment of LA to animals uh
which was issued in 2006 it was proposed
to be the first Chinese and Welfare uh
law or regulations but then re changed
the name to guidelines on human uh human
treatment of L animals because the
welfare word is very sensitive in China
so these guidelines uh emphasize the
need necessity and the importance of
training so they put training training
training of the uh Personnel in
here and uh uh we had a new uh National
Standard which is called uh the T that
is uh Society uh standards issued by the
kalas
uh in uh January
2016 so uh the lab animal related
Personnel are categorized into six
different types or different
classes uh so we have lab animal
technicians we have manager of lab
animal resources we have lab animal
veterinarian we have lab animal
researcher we have lab animal assistant
support practitioner we have lab animal
Feast practitioner so in total six type
of uh
personnels so for the lab animal
technician which by the way is pretty
much similar to the uh alas uh
categories just like the American
Association for lab animal science they
have uh certification programs with
different uh level of lab animal
technicians so uh for lab animal
technition uh very similar to the US
system we have assistant lab anim
technition we have lab anim technician
we have lab animal
technologist and for the manager of lab
animal resources uh which is pretty much
similar as the uh certified manager of
animal resources in the US so those are
the Personnel who manages lab animal and
other resources and operates animal
facilities so we have two levels one is
manager one is senior
manager so for the veternarians which
attract a lot of discussions and debates
so mainly by definition those lab animal
vs are responsible for lab animal
disease prevention diagnosis treatment
Medical Care and Animal Welfare so we
have three different levels which is uh
very different from the US um so in
China we have a assist lebum R we have
Leb R we have senior lebum R so in the
US you are either a veterinarian or a
board certified by the American College
of lebano medicine so they don't have
different levels of leban
vets but in ch we have three different
um um different
levels so for the lab animal researcher
or you can call them lab animal
scientists so they are the Personnel
researching on lab animal Science and
Technology we have three different uh
categories or levels Junior ones and neb
researcher and a senior NE
researcher and for the assistance
support practitioner which is U proving
unique in China those are the personnel
providing maintenance service for ad
facilities and equipment
manufacturer transport marketing and
waste disposal etc for Relevant La
products so this is pretty unique in
China this type of personnel and uh um
and we also have lab and Fe practitioner
means uh there might be medical doctors
and visiting student or scientists uh
who are involved with laap animals or
animal experiments during certain phase
of their work usually within one year so
they are temporary working with laary
animals so uh we do have uh requirements
as proposed by the uh standards which is
uh you know some of the fundamental uh
things are listed here so we have to
have full compliance with relevant laws
and regulations we have appropriate
Education and Training we meet the
health requirements that's for personal
you you do not you cannot have certain
infectious diseases or allergic
reactions otherwise we will be excluded
from um contacting with left animals
though the health requirements are for
personnel not for the animals don't be
get don't get confused uh you need to
obtain uh lab animal practitioners
certificate so those are some of the I'm
going to give you some of the uh brief
uh description about requirements on
working experience and qualification
exams for different types of uh
Personnel so for the assist one I'm not
going to go uh into very much detail
about this um requirements requirements
so there are some of the uh categories
are much similar uh compared with the
AAS on such as the assistant lab an
technicians you need to have at least a
high school diploma plus two years
working experience and pass exams I'm
going to give you a list or a table of
the different types of
exams or you have a higher degree which
is associate bachelor degree or above
and you can pass uh the A1 exam without
working experience required for the lab
tech
you have two or more years
experience and a pass
exam and you have bachelor degree you
need next time of working experience and
of course you need to pass the exam and
um senior
on and a manager you need to have a b
degree uh five years experience plus uh
uh three years uh experien in a manager
role and also pass
exam senior manager uh and because I'm a
veterinarian so I focus more on the lab
veterinarians so um in order to um sit
in the training and Examination for a
assistant lab animal vetar certificate
or qualification you need to have a kind
of associate or above degree in vet
managing usually for 3 years know L than
three years uh uh col education one or
more years working with natural animals
and past the uh C1
examination I cannot agree with that but
this is already written uh in the um uh
national standards so we're going to go
with this kind of U uh definition and go
with the training in the future and for
the lab animal veterinarians uh you need
to have a two or more years experience
after you get the um assistant leban V
certificate uh or you pass the national
assistant uh veter license qualification
and pass the C2 exam if you have a
bachor above degree in veteran medicine
or you have a national vet uh
qualification in China you only need one
or more years uh of experience and a
pass exam you'll get the LA certificate
and for the senior on
uh you need to have a few or more years
experience after your achieving Leb anal
V certificate and pass the C3 uh
examination and a junior lab researcher
uh lab
researcher and the senior n researcher
so you have two years after your Leb
research certificate and pass the
exam and uh for the uh assistant
supportive uh practitioners you need to
always no uh clear uh requirement for
that but you need to uh receive training
on basics of lab anual science and
techniques and obtain basic vocational
and professional qualification depending
on your
job and lab anual face practitioners and
uh it's no definition because they are
basically medical scientists or visiting
scientists or students so they need to
receive training on basics of lab animal
science and technicians and obtain
relevant qualification in their relevant
field and I need to mention that for
these kind of uh feced practitioners you
usually need to work under supervision
or under oversight of a qualified
Personnel like a lab animal that or a
lab animal
[Music]
technician and these just a table a list
of the certifying
examinations uh so different categories
you have different uh levels and you
have different uh exams to take to
prepare for and pass in order to get um
relevant
[Music]
certifications and we do have a
competency requirements for those
different type of lab animal
Personnel uh you need to have basic
knowledge of lab science and Welfare and
husbandry procedures we need to
understand certain important Concepts
theories and of those related um um
Fields like animal health disease
prevention F sity operation uh research
type of things of course the different
LEL the high level may have a higher
requirement for this uh type of
knowledge and
experience and for the manager in order
to do scientific things you need to have
uh certain understanding and experience
in managing people and managing budgets
and managing uh those kind of different
resources and for the Leb
uh lab animal you need to understand the
basic science of lab animals and you
need to understand NE welfare ethics and
regulations you need to be familiar with
diagnosis uh
monitoring uh there Health monitoring
prevention and treatment of um leim
diseases those are the common diseases
and you need to be familiar with lab
animal handling and manipulations like
like injection bleeding Etc and also be
familiar with tinesia and other
procedures and for the Le that you have
a higher level of expectation from the
uh uh qualification of certifying body
to have a better knowledge of those
listed for the assistant Leb and vet and
for the senior one you have to be a
master uh of the basics of n science and
Welfare uh disease
uh uh and also you need to supervise uh
relevant Laban procedures you have to be
uh uh providing consultation and
training to lab animal research uh
personnel and researchers pretty much
simar about the basic labim science uh
know about animal
experimentation and
um you are capable I mean for the lab
I'm researcher you should be capable in
participating in lab animal related uh
research
projects and for senior one you need to
be able to independently conduct lab
animal research and can supervise and
train a Julia lab an research
personnel and
uh for the feast practitioners you need
to have basic knowledge and you'll be
trained uh for certain things which are
helpful for your research in addition to
that you need to know about basic uh
animal ethics and Welfare and also know
about the occupational health and safety
issues when you are get in touch with
lapor so we have qualification training
and certification program uh which are
organized by the Chinese Association for
lab animal
Sciences so the uh train is
the potential trainers are labatory
animal practitioners who apply for
Relevant certifications so the
organization uh of uh kasas is actually
in the organizing body for uh issuing
those certification exams and then later
on if you pass exam they're going to
issue you with uh relevant
certificates uh so certifications as I
mentioned Kat is responsible responsible
for that and and uh kilas will set up
the relevant requirements and also
provide continuing
education uh Zain manages through the
kalas which is a central level
Association in China for Laban science
and we also have K of Branch um
Association for Laban science in
different uh
provinces
so K is responsible uh from the
administration level for Laban
practitioner qualification training and
certification exams and um also kalas is
responsible for evaluation and
qualification of uh training programs
and setting up the train uh
courses so as for the lab and
veternarians uh so the uh official
national Veterinary licensing
examination started in China in 2009
before that we had a long history of
examinations or licensing for pet
larians so they are working in the pet
clinic for dogs and cats but for the
farm animals for lab animals for World
animals for the animals in the zoo
settings we do not have a official
veteran license system to cover that but
uh it changed uh after
2009 and uh within the kalas uh we
established a lab animal medicine
working group in uh December
2016 to uh develop a kind of uh Ro
documents and set up the training course
and set up the certified exam question
database and with a final goal to
establish a Chinese College of labanon
Medicine and Final
joined the international um organization
which is called International
Association for college of lab medicine
uh which now uh has uh four uh members
which is American college and European
College Japanese college and the Korean
College of laary animal medicine so this
is a little bit uh different from the uh
Western practices
for instance the lab animal medicine
College which is uh part of the American
V Medical Association avma uh in China
we do have a Chinese veter Medical
Association but uh uh they are not very
active on uh developing Le so in in
reality we set up such a organization in
the killas system to promote the
training of Labon V in
China this is little bit
different so uh just following that
slide so our thinking for the Chinese
College of lab and medicine is that uh
you have to have a senior Leb V
certificate plus you have a China
National veteran license and then you
are eligible to be elected into the
Chinese College of Laban medicine
so um because now within the
globalization of research including uh
lab animal science uh the globalization
process so there are many foreigners or
International
experts uh uh who are working in China
right now or who uh will be or willing
to uh work in China in the near future
so you might have a
concern regarding uh how the uh lab
anual practitioners with a certain uh
foreign qualification certification uh
if they are be able to work directly uh
in China with such foreign
qualifications or need certain
assessments whatever so I can tell you
that there is currently no clear policy
or requirement yet regarding um how to
handle the lab animal practicians or lab
animal professionals with a uh foreign
qualification certification uh to work
in China um so that is um unfortunately
unfortunately no Mutual recognation of
qualification certifications uh between
China and the Western world not yet so
uh but uh our thinking is that at least
those uh International experts uh should
be trained on relevant Chinese
regulations and guidelines in order to
be permitted to uh work in China uh with
contact with
animals uh so just give you a brief idea
about the Chinese Association for lab
animal science we do have a training
plan each year so for the 2017 for this
year the training plan looks like the
following so we do have and iook
training which will be March 2017 we
have workshop for senior manager of lab
animal resources uh we have um K annual
meeting just like we have in the US AAS
meeting uh we have Adam welfare and
ethics Workshop we have national
standards training we have qualification
exams for different types of Na
practitioners uh we do have a training
for leban V which has been scheduled for
November
2017 we also have other training
opportunities unlike we have a Chinese
version of child short course on lab
animal science which have about three or
four uh different sides in China a
different time so you can choose to
attend which is more uh convenient for
you we have facility Management training
uh which was and will be sponsored by
the um by the techn plus uh company with
uh
oversight uh from the Beijing
Administration uh for lab animals uh in
China and we do have uh barrier facility
operations as a matter of fact in China
no matter what they doing uh you just do
a kind of Toxicology or certain other
things with laboratory rodents you need
to have a bar facility so that's the
role so no matter what you are doing you
need to have a barrier facility for
rodents so it's popular to have barrier
facility operation trains so each year
we have one is
co-organized by the Beijing
Administration for lab animals together
with the uh Capital Medical University
in Beijing so we do have seminars
workshops on humanized or genetically
modified an models with the focus on
mice and uh we have zebra fish workshops
probably a couple of workshops per year
in different places we do have non Prim
workshops because within the launching
of the China Brin um projects uh we uh
have a more focus on the n premit so we
have workshops reading regarding the non
prise as model for human diseases uh we
do have n primate workshops based on
mainly focus on um behavior and also the
uh training uh so that n Prim could be
more uh Cooperative with uh humans with
the
procedures and we also have access to
online NE medicine uh training courses
for example uh at the University of
Copenhagen we have a European designated
V uh training course I think we have at
least one or two uh vets register for
that course and is starting right now
starting for that course and we do have
access to introductive leban medicine
program at University of grow in Canada
I think we have about 30 or four labest
in China
achieved attended that program and
achieved a certificate for
that yeah uh that's all about my
presentation uh thanks very much for
your attention I will be more than happy
uh if you have any questions for me and
I have I'll try my best to answer
thanks thank you Dr Pang before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would just like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and if we don't get to your question
Dr ping will answer them post
presentation now our first question is
Dr
ping in China lab animal related
activities are regulated by which
Ministry at the central governmental
level
yeah thanks very much uh for this
question actually as I mentioned at the
beginning of this
presentation uh in China at the central
government level the ministry of Science
and
Technology you can call it most m is the
government body at a central government
level responsible for the administration
or regulation of lab animals related AC
activities in China so in short the
ministry of science and technology is
the government body for La science in
China next
question uh I'm audience members t i I
am a l as certified by
AAS do I need a license in order to be
able to work as a lab animal Tech in
China
uh this is a pretty good question as I
briefly mentioned during my presentation
with the globalization of science
research and also with NE animal science
um in China we do have certain uh
International experts working in China
like I mentioned uh if you have a lab
animal technician
certificate uh issued by the American
Association for L science which is
support recognized in China by your
employer but not by the Govern body
which is we do not have a mutual
agreement on the recognition of uh uh
certifications issued by different
countries uh like between us and China
that side I think you are more than
welcome to work in China but you may
need to go through a kind of um uh brief
um training regarding the relevant
regulations with respect to lab animals
in China so you can talk to or through
your employee to talk to the local uh
Administration office for lab animals
they probably can help arrange someone
can speak your language such as English
so that I can give you a brief
introduction about the relevant
regulations which are the basics you
need to know about and then uh in
addition to that I believe that the
organization you are going to work with
have internal training plan you need to
go through those things since you are
certified by the alas uh we we are
pretty confident you have a good amount
of the basic techniques you need to work
with animals in the in the field so
basically we will focus on the
regulation thing and let your employers
to decide which part of the technical
things you need to um to n and um uh and
to be certified by them so in short uh
you cannot automatically work in China
with a international certification but
rather you may be advised to take
certain uh brief training on the uh
regulation uh things about lab animals
in
China Dr ping I have a question that's
along the similar lines here um I have
another audience member who is a
licensed vet in the states and is also
acam boarded they would like to know if
they need a Chinese vet license to
practice lab animal medicine in
China yeah this is a a very good
question uh because I'm a vet also so I
can answer question probably in more
depth so basically as I mentioned that
you know the US vense is not officially
recognized in in China not yet at least
so in order to be a leban vet uh you
need to have a Chinese National veteran
license but don't be afraid because
usually by definition if you work only
in the lab animal facilities that is you
are going to work with laboratory
animals in a research setting so usually
you will not be required to have a
formal Ving license in order to be doing
that but as you mentioned that you have
a board certification from the American
College of lebano Medicine which is
highly regarded across world so we would
consider you as a expert in the labal
medicine but if you want to be a
attending V Marian in a facility because
by definition uh AV is a legal term
which is you are responsible for all the
veteran care issues or things in your
establishment or in your facility so you
have legal UH
responsibilities so you B have a v
license in China to practice or to feel
in that role so uh for you uh situation
my recommendation my suggestion would be
that you could be a kind of um uh
supervisor uh role like a director of
laboral medicine department or dep
director of Veteran care but you could
hire a uh vet with a child license to be
the attend V uh or you can
be uh I think it's not fair for you to
go through the uh veteran license exam
in China so you can be in a kind of U
manager type of role but not play a AV
role but um if those facilities are kind
of international organizations like uh
from a c uh Global C whatever in China
or have a lck
accreditation so as long as you are
recognized by your employer as a uh
competent V you can play as a attend V
also so in short um
officially you cannot be the attending V
in China but in reality in practice you
can given that you have a agreement with
your management top Management in China
and ideally you could have a
uh uh vet with a Chinese uh veteran
license to assist to
you very good thank you Dr ping and I
have one more question for you we're
almost out of time and I believe you
almost answered this question but I just
to
clarify um we'll just ask you this last
question in order to be qualified for an
attending vet job in China what
certificate do I need to have sen um
senior lab analyst vet lab animal vet or
even assistant lab animal
vet so this is a very good but a little
bit tricky question as I mention that by
definition if you want to be a atton vet
or a vet for lab animals you first need
to be a vet or certified vet or licensed
vet but with the situation in China and
as stated in the uh Chinese
uh national standards as I mentioned
during my presentation we have three
different levels of uh leban V assist NE
V NE and Senior NE vet so uh basically
by definition if you achieve at least
the you know assistant level and vet you
could be uh appointed as a vet for lab
animals in China uh you could also be a
t vet for that facility as well but uh
in my uh opinion so we're going to
implement a plan which is you you need
to have a veteran license because which
is regulated by the Ministry of
Agriculture in China so it would be a
kind of uh very um embarrassing
situation that you are not a licensed
vet in China and you play a veteran role
for lab animals so ideally you would
have a V license uh issued by the uh
Ministry of Agriculture either assistant
uh licensed vet or licensed vet
preferably and then uh you don't really
need a lebano vet certification from the
kalas you can be the vet which is also
recognized by the international
accreditation body which is El
International so in short uh you don't
really have to have a s leban or leban V
or even a senior leban vest uh in order
to be able to take on a v job but my
recommendation is that you achieve a lab
an license uh from the ministry of Agri
culture in China plus that you have
certain training and knowledge about lab
animal species you are going to uh uh to
take care of that is to achieve a one of
the three uh levels of V qualifications
issued by the
kalas thank you thank you Dr ping as I
mentioned we've run out of time and that
will have to be our last question but as
a reminder Dr ping will be answering any
questions submitted that were not
answered via
email I would like to thank again Dr
William Pang for his presentation Dr
Pang do you have any final comments for
our audience
yeah again thanks very much for your
invite and thanks much thanks very much
for your attention so my goal of this
presentation is give you a brief idea
about the uh regulatory system in China
so that you can be uh confident working
in China because it's not very different
from the uh other parts of the world and
then I just natur to know that we do
have a uh ucation training and the CPD
a program or strategic U uh uh program
in place but we are in an kind of infant
stage we
do and uh try to come up with a uh plan
which is most uh mostly suitable for
China situation and as I mentioned that
if you have a uh certification uh
acquired from the other parts of the
world world uh you are welcome to work
in China and we will help you go through
these assessments and uh to be able to
work in China uh to work in China for
China and for Global and to promote uh
good lab and Welfare and good animal
research in China and uh also in other
parts of the U Global yeah thank you
very
much thank you again Dr Pang I would
also like to thank our sponsor labroots
for making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on demand viewing through
May 9th
2017 you will receive an email from
labroots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you next time
goodbye